hey youtubers is Charlie remember that
time that Superman turned into a
werewolf now that's actually a thing
because they've cast Superman it's gonna
be Tyler hoechlin from Teen Wolf
do not be bummed that Tom Welling isn't
going to be Superman on Supergirl just
because he's not this version of
Superman doesn't mean he won't cameo on
the show at a certain point I definitely
think he'll a cameo I think there are a
lot of reasons why they decided to go
with Tyler hoechlin one because he's a
little bit hotter right now Tom Welling
hasn't been super active in the last
couple years and they really needed to
sell this show to a really broad
audience not just the people who were
fans of Smallville and if you haven't
seen him he's actually been in a couple
of movies recently he was just in
Richard Linklater's everybody wants some
with supergirls husband in real life
Melissa Benoist husband was the main
character in that movie Tyler hoechlin
was also one of the leads so there's
already been kind of a pseudo Supergirl
Teen Wolf crossover and another deep cut
for anybody that didn't watch Teen Wolf
Colton Haynes was on Teen Wolf before he
became Roy Harper so we've already got
werewolves in the DC Universe and even
Stephen Amell Oliver Queen played a
werewolf on Vampire Diaries
so you already see like the big genre
mashup rights itself there's been a
bunch of times Batman and Superman have
either turned into werewolves and
vampires or have fought them so I'll
talk about that in a second but
basically what's going on with Superman
on Supergirl season 2 is that he's going
to be in the first two episodes of the
season and then maybe show up in the
back half the whole point in them
casting a new version of Superman so
that they can have an actor come on
screen and actually interact with
Supergirl it's not going to be like text
messaging it's not gonna be him blurry
off screen like it was during season 1
on CBS so it'll be a real deal Superman
and I think this is largely due to some
of the changes that are going on behind
the scenes of the movies typically a
Warner Brothers the status quo was no
Superman no Batman on TV while they're
going on in the movies but now that
they've allowed Superman
they've teased Barbara Gordon on arrow I
think we'll slowly start to see some
more of those a list characters appear
on the TV shows and most of you are
asking like hey now that we actually
have a real Superman on screen when are
we gonna get Batman I think it's gonna
take a little bit longer and a lot of
that has to do with what's going on on
Gotham now they're working up to
man but they're kind of a prequel series
so Batman isn't Batman yet so it gets
really complicated when you think about
stuff like that so just assume
multiverse theory there is a Bruce
wayne/batman out there we'll see him
eventually but a rival date just to be
determined what about the Justice
Society though Superman is a huge part
of that well I think Supergirl is gonna
be more actively involved with the big
crossovers that they have because it's
her TV show
Superman is more of a guest so we might
hear him making offhanded remark jokes
references to Justice League Justice
Society things but I think when we do
like the big four night crossover if
there is Superman stuff he's gonna be
relatively minimal the real thing now is
I'm waiting for people to joke about
Holland Roden coming on as like Miss
Martian we've seen white Martians but we
haven't seen Miss Martian on Supergirl I
feel like she'd be an awesome character
just a really badass female character
for Supergirl to interact with but the
problem with that is that she's kind of
part of the Teen Titans universe and
they were previously tied up with
another TV show project which has
actually been lost in the Phantom Zone
so unless she's one of those characters
that's earmarked for another project I
think they could totally do Miss Martian
on Supergirl that would definitely be
the place to introduce her into the
multiverse what I really like to see
though is once they get to the point
where they introduce a whole bunch of
big super-powered characters they just
allow them to crossover independently of
the other characters on their shows
so like when Supergirl crosses over with
the flash you'll probably see some
Martian Manhunter things it would be
awesome if Martian Manhunter could just
go on somebody else's show by himself so
if you're wondering if we're gonna see
any scenes with Superman and Oliver
Queen interacting I'm not expecting that
but it's totally fair game it's all fair
game now that they're in the universe
when it comes to big Justice Society
crossovers because Legends is doing the
Justice Society story I think most of
the references to all that stuff
happening will be on that show each of
the shows is gonna have its own
storyline to pursue really when you're
gonna see like the peak comic book
moment where all the characters are
interacting with each other or joking or
referencing each other is gonna be
during that big four night crossover all
of the TV shows have been making a bunch
of casting announcements about
characters that are coming on mostly
hero characters there haven't been a lot
of villain announcements yet but I am
working on arrow in Justice Society
videos next I'll do new flash rebirth
video
so there's a bunch of details that we
have to talk about for all the TV shows
but I'll try to keep those in those
separate videos just because there's so
much going on right now just get really
hyped for just the society things
happening on all these TV shows they've
been casting a whole bunch of new
Justice Society characters so what about
vampires and werewolves in the
multiverse Cisco already made zombie
jokes because of zombie kurtter during
the flash season - and if you read
crisis on Infinite Earths they did have
vampire Superman from an earth that had
been completely turned into vampires for
like all the superheroes got bitten it
was like a world full of vampires I
think that was called Earth V but it was
just an offhanded ridiculous thing that
they just included for an easter-egg
vampire Superman is kind of ridiculous
sounding because vampires are a weak
against sunlight Superman is powered by
a sunlight so it doesn't really make
sense that Dracula would be able to turn
him but there was a storyline in the
Jimmy Olsen comic book way way back
where like all the classic monsters come
to life in Cadmus labs because a bunch
of bacteria gets transmitted through
this special device so you have
Frankenstein Dracula
the werewolf the mummy all going after
Superman but typically anytime you see
Batman or Superman fighting werewolves
zombies any of the classic monsters it
tends to be a one-off story and it's
something that exists in like an
alternate universe so I think the
closest we'll actually get to seeing the
characters in the TV universe fight
werewolves and vampires is when Cisco
makes jokes about it on the flash so let
me know in the comments what do you
think about Tyler hoechlin
and how do you want to see the show use
Superman in the future Supergirl itself
and then in big crossovers I feel like
everybody wants to see a big Justice
League Justice Society team-up episode
they're already doing Justice Society so
we're halfway there but what's gonna
happen next just because I haven't done
a Marvel video in a little while I'm
gonna do a new Civil War video they're
teasing the Hulk killing the Marvel
Universe which I just love because
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe was a
really fun storyline in the comics now
they have Hulk kills the Marvel Universe
so be sure to subscribe to get that
video should post in a couple hours and
then I'll do an arrow season 5 video for
the new Omar character from the wire
that they've cast now they didn't get
the actor Omar I made a joke about this
and I feel like half of the people
didn't get it when I said arrow season 5
cast Omar from the wire
they cast a new character from the
comics who's playing a vigilante whose
superpower is blowing the out of
people with regular guns so arrows doing
a character that is very like almost
exactly like Omar from the wire which is
really funny because I always talk about
arrow wire references but then after
that there'll be some flash season three
flash rebirth stuff from the comics so
all kinds of Marvel DC stuff happening
this week wait guys wait for that video
to post you can click here for my Game
of Thrones episode 9 trailer and you can
click here to watch South Park roast the
out of Marvel and DC movies is the
greatest thing ever thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight